>> male presenter: So, It's my pleasure today
to welcome Dr. Susan Barry, author of " Fixing
My Gaze " and Professor of Biological Sciences
at Mount Holyoke College.
Dr. Barry received her PhD. in 1981 from Princeton
University and has pursued her research of
neuroscience at NASA's Johnson Space Center
and
the Marine Biological Laboratory in Woods
Hole, among other institutions.
So, in the summer of 2006, I listened to NPR's
"Morning Editionî during my commute every
day.
I remember hearing an interview with a neuroscientist
who gains stereo vision in middle age, when
everyone thought that couldn't be done in
infancy.
And she described the joy of seeing a snowfall
in three dimensions for the first time, and
I had to wipe my eyes a little on the way
to the office.
Not quite a year after that, I started dating
a beautiful and brilliant woman, who, invited
me to meet her family at their Passover Seder.
And by the way, she said, my mom is a little
obsessed with stereo vision.
So, my mother in-law, Dr. Susan Barry, stereo
[ inaudible ]. :
[ Applause ]
>> Susan Barry: Thanks, David, for that introduction.
I think my daughter is brilliant, partly because
she married you.
OK.
So, today I am going to tell you about the
story in my book, which is a story about how
I rehabilitated my own vision with the help
of a developmental optometrist in a way that
people thought-- scientists, physicians, thought--
was impossible.
And to understand how that happened, you really
have to go back and think about how, what
it is that we use our vision for to begin
with.
OK?
And to get at that question, I thought I'd
show you a slide of an animal on the first
slide.
Does anyone know what this animal is?
You guys need to get out from the building,
and go down to Cape Cod, and scoop your hands
under the pier.
And you'll see these little animals that look
sort of like a hot water bottle.
This animal is called a Tunicate, or a Sea
Squirt.
And they're actually in the Chordate Phylum,
which is our phylum.
So, they're our distant cousins.
And the reason I am mentioning this animal
to you is because, when it's in its larvae
form, it's juvenile form, it looks sort of
like a tadpole.
And it swims about and it has two eyes and
a brain.
And then, when it finds a suitable place to
live, it literally sticks its head in the
sand and converts itself to this adult form,
which is simply a filter feeder.
It just brings in water, sieves water right
through its body, extracting the plankton
from the water for its food.
But, it never uproots itself again.
It just stays in one place for the rest of
its life.
And in the course of converting itself from
this larval swimming form to the adult sessile
form, it loses its eyes and most of its brain.
Because, you donít need eyes or much of a
brain if you donít move.
The major role of vision is allowing us to
move.
Think about it.
Organisms that donít move, like plants, donít
uproot themselves to move.
Like, plants donít have eyes and they donít
have a brain.
The major role of vision is to allow us to
know where we are in space, and where everything
else around us is in space.
So, we can move accurately and manipulate
those objects.
OK?
So, how do we know how to do that?
Well, think about if you only had one eye
in the middle of your head, like a cyclops.
Then, I would know for example, that I was
looking out the window on my right, because
I'd move my one single cyclopean eye to the
right.
And I would know that I was looking, for example,
at the projector more or less straight ahead.
Because I have now moved my single eye to
be straight ahead on my head.
And my head is facing straight forward.
But, we donít have one eye.
We have two.
And the fact that we have two eyes overlapping
visual fields, makes the whole situation both
more sophisticated, but also more complicated.
So, I want you all to do this little experiment.
Take you index finger and just put it a comfortable
distance from your face.
But, straight ahead.
Straight in front of your nose.
And now I am gonna ask you, you know you are
looking straight ahead.
You're looking at your finger, which is straight
ahead.
But it's either one of your eyes actually
pointing straight ahead.
Well?
No.
You've got one eye that is--.
Your right eye is pointing a little bit to
the left.
And your left eye is pointing a little bit
to the right.
What is straight ahead, is where the line
of sight of the two eyes cross.
As it's shown in this picture here.
And then, if you follow these lines, and you
imagine this target as you're finger that
you were just looking at, then, you can see
that the image of the finger is cast on the
retina in the back of the eye.
On the central part of the retina called the
fovea.
But, it's cast on corresponding points of
the two eyes.
OK?
And, so, your brain makes a conclusion.
It says, "My finger, whose image was cast
on the corresponding points of the retinas
of my two eyes.
I have two images of that finger.
One from my right eye, one from my left."
But, those two images are falling on corresponding
points of the two retinas.
And, therefore, there is only one finger there.
Not two.
And more important it's located in one unique
location in space.
OK?
And similarly if we look at this picture here,
the two eyes are bi fixating on the block.
The image of the block falls on the same central
part of both retinas.
And, these two toys here, the teddy bear and
the rattle are falling basically in the same
frontal parallel plane as the block.
And if you look to see where their image is
cast, then, you can see that for example,
the image of the teddy bear is cast to the
right of that central region.
And the same number of degrees to the right
of the central region for the left and right
eye.
And so, your brain will think, OK, I have
two images of the teddy bear.
One for my right and one for my left eye.
But, they are falling on corresponding retinal
points.
And, therefore, there is only one teddy bear.
And it's located in one unique location in
space.
And that location on the Z axis is roughly
the same as the point I am fixating.
Where my two eyes are meeting.
OK?
Or, the line of sight of the two eyes are
meeting.
So, that all works perfectly well, as long
as your eyes point to the same place in space,
at the same time.
But, what happens if they donít?
And, that was my situation, because, I'd been
cross-eyed all my life.
So, when I looked with one eye, the other
eye turned in and looked someplace else.
And, I rapidly switched between which eye
was looking, letís say, straight at you,
and which eye was turned in.
So, the two eyes were not pointing at the
same place in time.
And that makes figuring out where things are
located in space, and , how many things there
are out there.
A much more difficult situation.
And in fact there are two major consequences
of having misaligned eyes.
Having two eyes that are not pointing to the
same place in space at the same time.
And one is diplopia, or, double vision.
Which I'll talk about in a little while, And
the other is Visual Confusion.
Which is a term coined by the famous psycho
physicist, Helmholtz, the man who invented
the ophthalmoscope, and was brilliant in a
bazillion different ways.
He termed the coin term--.Or, he coined that
term.
And, let me explain to you what it is.
Yeah.
>>male #1: When you're talking about not having
you two eyes not pointing--.
>> Susan Barry: At the same place.
>> male #1: At the--.
In the same direction.
Or, not pointing at the same thing.
Right?
>> Susan Barry: Right.
>> male #1: But, assuming that the fields
of vision still overlap, assuming that the
skew is not so large, then you are getting
an image of the two things, right?
It's just that they're not both foveal, right?
They're not both in the fovea.
So, is it really, is there something biologically
intrinsic about the fovea that lets you know
that that's where the two corresponding images
should be?
Do you not make up for--?
>> Susan Barry: It's your reference point.
It's your reference point.
It's the center of the retina for both eyes.
It's where you have the greatest number of
photo receptors.
It's where the visual cortex is paying the
most attention.
So, it's your reference point.
This is the same place in both eyes.
And, then, like I showed you in this picture
here, if we use the fovea then as our reference,
then , where other images fall relative to
the fovea on both eyes, becomes important.
>> male#1: Right.
>> Susan Barry: And, when you say is this
an innate biological--.
That seems to be the way it works.
>> male#1: So, you don't make up for it by
picking some other point as your reference
point?
Having to use the fovea on one eye, and, use
some ex-foveal point as the reference.
>> Susan Barry: Actually, that is an adaptation
that can develop in people with a long term
strabismus, and, it's called anomalous correspondence.
And that allows you to use both eyes, and,
look though both of them even though their
looking at different things.
But, yes.
>> male#1: Standard way of dealing with it.
>> Susan Barry: It's not.
And, it's also not the first way of dealing
with it.
It's an adaptation that develops over time.
Yes?
>> male#2: And, then, when you do that you
pick a different point, but, it's always the
same point?
>> Susan Barry: Well, that would be if it's
harmonious anomalous correspondence.
[ laughter ]
>> Susan Barry: And that would depend upon
the fact that your two eyes are always misaligned
to the same degree.
Whether you're looking close, or, you're looking
far.
Which is called comitant stabismus.
If your strabismus is incomitant , meaning
that you, mine was incomitant, meaning that
my eye misalignment was different looking
close, than further away.
Then, it's harder to develop an anomalous
correspondence.
Because, the two eyes are not in the same
relationship with each other.
Looking close and far.
>> male#2: I'll take a guess here and say
if you get harmonious, you get stereo, and
if you don't get harmonious you get--.
>> Susan Barry: You may have some crude stereo
vision with harmonious correspondence.
But, because images that fall outside of the
fovea are less well resolved, and are seen
less well, it's not the same as combining
two foveal images.
Or, even combining two parafoveal images.
But, that are falling at the same place parafoveally.
The two images are not identical.
Yeah.
What you're getting at right from the get
go, some of the complications and subtleties
of strabismus.
Which most scientists and physicians don't
go so far as to think about.
And, so, they think " oh strabismus, easy
to understand.
They use one to press the other.
End of story."
And now, you're seeing that it's really actually
much, much more complicated than that.
OK.
So, anyway, we've got the situation where
the two eyes are pointing at different places
in space.
And I was telling you that there two consequences
to that, diplopia, which means double vision,
and visual confusion.
So, let's start with visual confusion.
And, what I want you to think about is this.
Here's the left eye.
It is fixating on the rattle.
The rattle is falling on the fovea.
The central part of this retina.
Here's the right eye, it's turned in.
Its fovea is not looking at the rattle.
Its fovea is looking at the block.
The default way that the brain works, is to
say that the two foveal images must be in
the same spatial location.
The same place in space.
So, if one eye is foveating the rattle, and
the other eye is foveating the block, the
result is you see the rattle and the block
in the same place in space.
Which as you can see, would be a fairly untenable
situation.
And, well, you might also think, now, that's
kind of interesting.
But, I could never experience that myself.
But, actually, if you do have two reasonably
good eyes and reasonable binocular vision
we can all experience visual confusion with
the hole in the hand experiment.
Has anyone ever done this?
It's great cocktail party fodder.
So, do you all have a piece of paper?
If you donít, I can give you one.
>> Susan Barry: OK.
So, what I want you to do is take that piece
of paper, roll it up to about the diameter
of a toilet paper roll.
So that you can put your right eye through
it and look through it.
As in eye spy.
And, then, go ahead and look at me for a second.
I want you to take your left hand, put the
right hand, I mean, put the tube over the
right eye, and put the left hand so that it
is toward the very end of the roll of paper.
Not over it, so it blocks your view through
the right eye.
But, next to it.
Open both eyes and tell me what you see.
>> Susan Barry: Do you see the hole in the
hand?
>>male#3: I donít have stereo vision.
[ laughter ]
>> Susan Barry: Yeah.
But, did many of you see something that looked
like this?
Hole in the middle of your hand.
Was anyone in pain?
So, think about what's happening there.
The central part of one eye is seeing the
hole through the tube.
The central part of the eye other can't see
that because of the tube, and it sees the
middle of the hand.
And so your brain says, "Well, the central
part of one eye is seeing is the hole.
The central part of the other eye is seeing
the hand.
Since corresponding retinal points are seeing
these two different things, they must be in
the same place in space."
And, you see the hole in the middle of your
hand.
And, so, that's an example of visual confusion.
Obviously an artificial one, but, it's probably
the most detrimental consequence of strabismus,
is this overlap of things in visual space.
Which makes obviously moving through space
very difficult.
OK?
And then, of course, the second consequence
of misaligned eyes is double vision.
Which some people may have experienced if
they drank a little bit too much.
Maybe not in this crowd.
And, let's figure out how double vision works.
Again, think about the rattle.
Its image is cast on the fovea of one eye.
But, if the second eye is turned, that image
is now falling on a non-foveal point.
OK?
On a different place on the retina of the
other eye.
And so the brain says, " I have two images
of the rattle.
One from my right and one from my left eye.
They're not falling on corresponding points.
So, maybe there are two rattles.
And, they're located in two separate locations
in space."
And that, of course, is double vision.
OK.
So, when I was a child, my strabismus- my
crossed eyes- also called infantile esotropia,
developed within the first months of life.
And as a result I adapted fairly rapidly to
the strabismus.
So, maybe I didnít adapt fairly rapidly,
cause my parents told me a was a really difficult
infant and toddler.
But, I adapted and the way I adapted was to
suppress the input from one eye.
So, I would look with one eye and turn in
the other.
And, pay attention to the input from the straight
eye.
And essentially ignore or suppress the input
from the turned eye.
And so, I do not remember many incidences
of seeing double as a child or an adult before
I underwent my vision therapy.
And, but there are people who develop strabismus
- misaligned eyes- later on in life.
And maybe plagued with a continual double
vision.
They always see images as double.
And I was very curious as to what this was
like.
And I had a student with exactly this situation.
And, so, one day over coffee I asked her what-
How it was that she coped.
And I want to read for you from a section
from my book about what she said.
And, so, it goes like this, "one of my students,
Sarah, developed a form of strabismus when
she was five years old.
And began to experience constant double vision
in high school.
I wanted to know if she coped.
So, one day over coffee I asked Sarah what
her view of the world was like.
" She said, " I see two images, but, only
one is real.
I could be driving and seeing two images of
a car, But, I know which one to steer around."
"This sounded bazaar.
Not to mention dangerous, so, I asked her
how she knew.
Sarah thought about this for a moment and
she tried to put into words came automatically
to her.
Then she said that the car image seemed like
her right eye was in context.
In other words the right eye image of the
car was located relative to other things in
her surroundings.
To Sarah, it had a defined location in space.
She added that in class, she might see two
images of me at the blackboard.
But, again, only the right eye image was real.
I was curious.
Does my voice come from the image seen by
the right or left eye.
Sarah hesitated but said that, the voice came
from the image seen by the right eye.
If I were to shake hands with you, she added,
I could reach accurately for and shake only
the hand seen by the right eye."If I tried
to use the left eye image, I'd miss your hand.
Itís not that I think about this, I just
reach for your hand automatically using the
right eye image."
"I pointed to the coffee mug in front of her.
From which of your two coffee cup images does
the delicious coffee aroma come from?"
"Now that you mention it, she said, It only
comes from the cup image seen by the right
eye."
So, think about what Sarah had to do.
She had two images of everything.
She has to interact with the world.
One of those images had to be the interact-able
image with.
One of those images had to be the one that
she reached for or moved around.
And so on.
And so, she--.
Her brain unconsciously made a decision about
which of those images was the real image.
And that was the image that was imbued with
all the other physical characteristics.
Like the smell coming from the coffee cup.
Or, the voice coming from me as I was talking
in front of the class.
And again you might say that real-unreal dichotomy;
that seems pretty bazaar.
I can't imagine experiencing it.
Well, we can all experience that too, or,
many of us can who have reasonable binocular
vision.
And here's the trick.
So, take your hand again, hold up your index
finger, and put it in front of your face.
But, this time don't look at it.
Look at me or look further in the distance.
Can you get a double image of your finger?
OK?
That's called physiological diplopia.
It's absolutely normal.
It's because you're fixating further away.
So, your finger image is falling on disparate
parts of the two retinas.
Perfectly normal.
OK?
So now, get that double image again and then,
very quickly take your right hand and try
to grab both of those images.
Keep looking in the distance, if you look
at the finger it'll single out.
So, keep looking in the distance.
[ pause ]
>> Susan Barry: So, I'm seeing a little bit
of this and this, then ,or maybe this over
here.
You see what I'm getting at?
Even though you're not walking around with
continual double vision, when placed with
the task of grabbing your finger when you
have two images of it, your brain automatically
selected one of those images as real.
One of those images as manipulate-able.
One of those images is the one you could grasp.
And, that's the decision that Sarah had to
make on a continual basis.
Until she went to see my optometrist and went
through optometric vision therapy.
And now, her double vision is largely resolved
and she's in Optometry school.
So, anyway, these are some of the consequences
of having crossed eyes.
And, of course, the third consequence is a
lack of binocular vision, it's a lack of stereo
vision.
The ability for example, to enjoy 3D movies.
I made this slide before "Avatar" and the
big 3D movie phenomenon came along.
Many of you have probably used " View Masters
" and you have a sense of what I mean when
I say, seeing in 3D.
I had three operations on my eyes as a child
to make them straighter.
And, although the operations made my eyes
look straighter, it didnít really change
the way I used them.
I still continued to look with one eye and
turn in the other.
It's just now, the eye turn is more subtle.
So, most people didn't notice it.
But I remember after my third operation being
given a View Master and everyone else in the
family seemed to enjoy looking into it.
And, I had no idea what they were seeing.
I mean, Mickey Mouse and Superman looked cute
inside the View Master, but, I didn't really
understand what it was that they were seeing.
Because, I still continue to see the image
as flat, because I was really only basically
paying attention to the input from only one
eye.
OK.
So, how does stereopsis, or the ability to
see in 3D work?
Real quickly again, it has to do with the
comparison between the images on the two retinas.
So, letís say your eyes are fixating, are
looking at the point called fix, then its
image is falling on corresponding retinal
points.
Now, take a look at target.
That image is not in the same frontal parallel
plane as fix, but, either somewhere--.
In this case it's behind it.
Although we can do an analogous analysis if
it were in front of the point called fix.
Follow the dotted lines and look to see where
that image is cast on the two retinas and
you can see that image is not cast on corresponding
points.
This distance, "X", is a number of degrees
from the fovea of the left eye that's different
than this distance, "Y", or angular distance
"Y" number of degrees from the fovea on the
right eye.
And then, your brain makes new interpretation.
The two images are falling on non- corresponding
points.
There's only one image out there.
It must be in some unique location in space.
And by dint of how it falls on one retina
relative to the other, it assigns it a place
in space that's either in front or behind
the other image.
And, of course that's what happens when you
go to a 3D movie, you're wearing glasses that
present images seen from slightly different
perspectives as if they were seen from your
two eyes.
And your brain then makes that interpretation,
"Oh the image is a little different on the
two retinas and therefore, it's either located
in front or behind the fixation point.î OK?
So, that's basically how 2D vision works and
obviously if you don't point your two eyes
at the same place in space, if the eyes are
misaligned, youíre not going to see in 3D.
And, operations to fix or try and realign
the eyes may not work.
Why may they not work?
Because think about this, think about an infant,
a child by the age of one year has already
learned how to use their eyes to reach for
things.
You start reaching for things at about the
age of three or four months of age.
Which is, incidentally is the same period
of time when infantile esotropia- crossed
eyes- first develops.
Makes sense.
If youíre trying to reach for things and
the eyes are not well aligned, you're gonna
have to do something about it.
And one thing you could do, maybe your eyes
are just a little bit misaligned, but now
if you misaligned one of the eyes even more,
cross it in even more, it's even easier to
ignore its input.
So, by the time youíre a year old, you know
how to reach for things.
You have been looking at things from a lying
down position, a sitting position, perhaps
you're cruising around and walking.
Your visual habits have become imbedded by
the time you're a year old.
And that's why I think surgery on its own
can't fix the problem.
Because, in order for you to learn how to
use your eyes in a different way.
That is point them at the same place at the
same point in time.
You have to be taught.
This is something you learn naturally within
the first year of life.
But, after that period of time, if you've
developed different visual habits, you have
to learn it in a whole new way.
OK?
So, that's the situation that I was in.
>> male#4: Why do some people block out second
eye images?
>> Susan Barry: Well, actually, I will tell
you an interesting adaption that I used.
So, when I first-.
I went to see a developmental optometrist
at the age of 48.
I didn't go to see her to gain stereo vision.
The dogma was that if you didnít develop
stereo vision within early childhood, what
was called the critical period in early childhood,
your brain wired itself up in a way that it
couldnít rewire.
And, you were permanently stereo blind.
And, I had read all the papers supporting
this idea.
And I used to lecture about that in class.
And I used to tell people, " I'm an example
that shows how well this theory of critical
periods, fits reality".
I was cross- eyed since infancy, Iím stereo
blind.
OK?
But, what I'm telling you is; you develop
certain adaptations, like you were asking,
to be able to see.
And, I'll tell you one adaptation I developed.
I went to see my developmental optometrist
because my gaze was jittery.
Especially in the distance.
It was very hard to keep my eyes stable on
anything.
And, so, that's why I went to see her.
I really wanted to have more confidence and
competence for driving my children around
town.
I found it very difficult to drive.
Look at a road sign and then go back to the
road, it just was very hard.
OK?
That's when I went to see her.
And she told me how it was that I learned
to read.
So, I had trouble learning to read in school.
It took until about fourth grade to catch
up to what other kids were doing.
And, the way I learned to read was this way.
When I looked at a book, I would look with
one eye at the letters, and the other eye
would turn in about fifteen degrees, or, 25
prism diopters.
Why fifteen degrees?
Well, if you look at the eye, the image, letís
say the letters, from the eye that was doing
the reading, fell on the fovea.
The other eye was turned by fifteen degrees,
so, the image fell on the blind spot.
On the place where the optic nerve leaves
the retina and goes to the rest of the brain.
So, in other words, while one eye was looking
at the letters, the other eye did not see
those letters at all.
Because, the image of those letters fell on
the blind spot.
What a perfect adaptation.
I can't really claim credit for it . It certainly
wasn't a conscious thing, but, that is eventually
how I learned to read.
But, was by making this adaptation.
And, fifteen degrees is a very common degree
of eye turn for people with strabismus.
And it makes sense.
It puts the foveal image of eye on to the
blind spot of the other, a beautiful adaptation.
>> male#5: It takes away almost the double
vision.
>> Susan Barry: It takes away almost the double
Especially for what youíre paying attention
to.
What's on the fovea.
And, you might say, " well if you can do that
why donít you just put the two images on
the fovea?"
But, the blind spot is a much bigger area.
Much bigger target to aim for than the very
tiny fovea.
OK?
So-.
>>male#6: So, I had lateral strabismus when
I was born.
And I had an operation when I was one or something.
It was very painless and I donít remember
a thing about it, it went pretty well.
I still have a problem, I don't know if I
have stereovision or not.
I definitely notice sometimes when I'm really
tired.
And, every once in a while something will
click and itís like, um, itís like, uhÖwhen
I bring the two images together I'll know
it.
I don't know, it's like the second eye is
aligning.
>> Susan Barry: That's probably what's happening.
Yeah.
We could- I have some tools you could try
afterwards and see.
>> male#6: So, Maybe it's gotten better since
then.
>> Susan Barry: Yeah, well, you can probably
tune it up.
You can probably tune it up.
But, yeah, I think your experience of the
double vision, or the eyes looking in, that's
an example of getting them into better alignment.
>> male#6: So, why not do the surgery for
infants?
Instead of--
>> Susan Barry: Well, the surgery is more
successful if it's done on a child before
the age of one.
Before, like I said, the visual habits become
entrenched.
But, it's hard to catch a child at that young
an age.
And there's risks to doing surgery on a very
young infant.
And there may be- Those are some of the issues.
And usually surgery alone, if a child does
develop stereopsis, stereo vision afterwards,
it's not as good as the normal stereo vision.
So, vision training at the age when they would
have been old enough to do it would still
probably be recommended.
But, yeah those are some of the issues out
there.
OK.
So then, the question is I've sort of explained
to you the problem.
And now, I want to give you a little bit of
an idea of the solution.
How did my optometrist teach me to use my
two eyes together?
To point at the same place in space at the
same time.
And to do that, one of the tools that she
used--.
By the way, she was a developmental optometrist,
which is a small set of optometrists who work
on this optometric vision therapy.
Vision therapy to train binocular vision.
And they're a very rare group of eye doctors.
To be distinguished from ophthalmologists
who do surgery.
OK.
Different types of eye doctors with different
types of expertise.
OK.
So, one of the techniques that she used was
developed by my hero.
A man named, Frederick Brock.
Who passed away in 1971, I never did meet
him.
But what Frederick Brock understood was that
stereovision, the ability to see with two
eyes, is not a passive process.
For most of us, if you have normal binocular
vision, when you look at something close,
you automatically turn your two eyes in together.
Make a convergence movement.
So that the image is close that you want to
fixate, falls on corresponding retinal locations
on the fovea of both eyes.
When you then shift your gaze to something
further away, you turn out, or diverge the
eyes.
These are vergence movements.
They develop in children within the first
two, four, months of life.
Or, if youíre like I was, and had infantile
esotropia, they don't develop.
OK?
And so, I basically had to learn how to make
vergence movements.
I had to learn something that most people
learned at two months of age and I learned
at the age of 48.
And one of the tools that I used was developed
by Frederick Drove Brock.
And I wanna stress that's it's only one of
many.
But it was my absolute favorite was the "Brock
String" and that's the string you all have.
Do you all have a--?
Well I have some others if there's somebody
here who needs one.
And there's more.
[ pause ]
OK.
So, here's what you do.
Take the bead on the Brock String, which is
basically a household piece of string.
And put it all the way to one end.
The string should be about arm's length.
Put the string up to the bridge of your nose
and look at the bead.
And, hopefully you see one bead.
But how many string images do you see?
>>male#7: Six.
[ laughter ]
>> Susan Barry: How many string images?
Do any of you see two string images?
OK.
Now take the bead and put it in the middle
of the string.
For some of you it might be easier if the
bead is closer to your nose, some further
away.
But put it at about the middle of the string.
Look at the bead again.
Hopefully again you see it as single.
And now, tell me, do you see something that
looks like this?
So, you see a bead in the middle of an "X"
configuration right?
Where there are two images converging on the
bead and then two images diverging away from
it.
Well when I first began to do this exercise
I was overwhelmed.
Because, this exercise told me where my two
yes were pointing in space.
It told me the line of sight of the two eyes.
I didn't know what eye I was using at any
one time.
I didn't know how I used my eyes.
I had to bring that information into conscious
awareness, in order to be able to change the
way I moved my eyes.
OK?
And this exercise gave me that information.
So, when you were looking at the bead, this
string image was actually the image coming
from your right eye.
And this was the image coming from your left.
And when I started the procedure, The only
way I could get that double string image and
the " X ", was if the bead, and this is very
common in somebody with my condition, infantile
esotropia, the only way I could get the "X"
is if I put the bead practically up to my
nose.
Within an inch of my nose.
And then I could get the "X" image.
And then I started gradually moving the bead
further away from me, getting that "X" image
and keep going on.
Sometimes I'd see only one image of the bead,
and one image of the string.
What did that mean?
I was suppressing one eye.
Sometimes I saw both images of the string
but they werenít coming in at the bead.
So, I knew that I was turning on the input
from both eyes but they weren't aligned.
Well with this feedback, so simple, yet so
elegant, I could learn how to point the two
eyes at the same place in space at the same
time.
And I didn't stop with a little string like
this.
I ended up using an eleven foot string.
And, with five beads along it and I would
look at the close bead and get the " X " and
then look at the further bead, and the next
bead, and so on, and so on, and so on.
And this way, training my eyes to bi-fixate
on different distances in space.
And, I still do these exercises on a regular
basis while jumping on a trampoline.
Or striding along on a NordicTrack, because
if I am going to be binocular I need to be
binocular.
Not just when I am standing still, but when
I'm moving.
OK?
And I wanna tell you about the time- And I'm
remembering it was February 21st, 2002.
I remember this day like it was yesterday.
When I was doing vision therapy at my developmental
optometristís office with a vision therapist,
I did therapy for a year.
One week for a year.
Once a week for a year.
And practiced at home every day.
And the exercise was to look at a close bead,
and I had just gotten to a point where I could
do that very well with a single bead.
And now I graduated to using two beads.
And the therapist said "OK, look at the close
bead."
I said yep I got it, got the "X."
Now, she said, "Look at the further bead."
And I looked at her and said, ìYep, I got
the ëXíî "Now look at the close bead, now
look at the further bead."
And I said to her, ìI can feel my eyes movingî.
I could feel them turning in to see the closer
bead.
I could feel them turning out together.
In coordination to see the further bead.
I said to her, I feel my eyes moving.
And, she said, "That's great.
We'll do it a little longer then we'll move
on to another activity."
I said to her, ìNo, I don't wanna stop.
I just wanna keep doing this.
I just want to feel the way this feels.
I want to remember how this feels, so I can
use this, when I don't have a Brock String
with me.î And, it was that afternoon, after
that vision therapy session, that I went out
to my car and sat down in the driver seat;
and I looked at the steering wheel, and it
was floating in front of the dashboard.
With this palpable volume of space between
the steering wheel and the dashboard and I
had never seen anything like that before.
And I thought to myself, could this be stereo
vision?
And then I thought , no way.
I'm a neuroscientist.
I know what I teach in class.
It was the day after my 48th birthday.
I was more than 40 years past the critical
period for the development of stereopsis.
This had to be something different.
The sun was setting, and I thought, oh the
sun is casting the light into the car at an
odd angle.
And this must explain what is going on.
[ laughter ]
OK.
But the next day I went out to my- I did my
vision therapy exercises in the morning, including
the Brock String, and I went to the car to
drive to work, and I went to address the rear
view mirror, and it was floating in front
of the dashboard.
And, all that day my vision began to change.
And all that month.
Well, there were many other vision therapy
exercises that I did.
I'm not going to go through them here now.
Because I just want to tell you, you can ask
me some more about them afterwards if you'd
like.
Because I just want to tell you what it's
like to first see the world when you can point
two eyes at the same place in space at the
same time.
It was a remarkable change.
One that I could never have predicted.
That is certainly not in the textbooks where
they look at stereopsis as just a little frosting
on the cake when it comes to vision.
It completely transformed the way I saw.
So, take trees.
All of a sudden I could see- I always knew
that trees, the canopy of a tree was round,
right?
But I never saw it that way.
To me a tree was like a kid's drawing, it
was just flat looking when you looked at it
front on.
And now, all of a sudden, I could see how
the outer branches enclosed and captured whole
volumes of space through which the inner branches
came through.
It was just absolutely spectacular.
Snowfall.
My first snowfall , David referred to that,
was just unbelievable.
My first snowfall in stereo.
Because I could see how each flake occupied
its own region of space, And there were these
palpable pockets of space between one flake
and another.
And all together they produced a beautiful
three dimensional dance.
One of the things I mention to people, because
it seems to- people seem to relate to this,
with my view of a mirror.
In the past when I looked at my reflection
in a mirror, my image was on the plane of
the mirror, not behind it.
It was on the plane of the mirror.
So much so, if there was a speck of dirt on
the mirror, I thought it was on my clothes,
and would try to wash it away.
And I remember the day when I looked in a
mirror and my image was no longer on the plane
of the mirror, but somewhere behind it.
In reflected space.
And that's when I understood what " Lewis
Carol " meant when he titled one of his books,
" Through The Looking Glass."
When I look through a window now, instead
of having the image just sort of flattened
onto the--.
Within the frame of the window, I now see
it in three dimensions extending great distances
beyond the window.
That was a real revelation.
And I am still confused by reflection.
Because if youíre sitting- One day I was
sitting in a restaurant, and it was Christmas
time and I am sitting here, and to my left
on the opposing wall of the restaurant was
a bunch of lights.
Christmas lights.
Which were reflected by the window onto the
street outside.
And I looked outside and I saw the reflected
lights not on the plane of the window, but
somewhere out there in space.
And I thought, why did they string Christmas
lights in the middle of the street.
And then, of course I realized what was going
on, I'm totally captivated by the way reflections
have this three dimensional field to them
that I had never appreciated before.
There were some surprising consequences of
seeing in 3D that went beyond just that the
sense of depth.
That sense of pockets of space between things.
And that one was edges in objects perhaps
because now I could locate them so much more
precisely.
Took on a sharpness and a definition that
I never seen before.
So take this painting for example, by Ingres
which is in the Metropolitan Museum of Art,
in New York.
And, take a look at the creases and folds
in the princess's gown.
I used to look at a painting like that and
think, "Gosh it's gorgeous", but, nobody sees
that way.
Nobody actually sees the crinkles and the
creases with such sharp definition.
And then, after my vision changed, yes indeed,
I did see them that way too.
So, edges and borders became much, much sharper.
We have a way of understanding depth called,
motion parallax.
Which means that as you move like this, back
and forth, images close to you appear to move
at a faster rate than images further away.
And also, in an opposite direction of images
further away.
And that gives you a sense of depth that you
can see with one eye.
But even that sense of depth was greatly enhanced
when I had this special quality of stereovision.
The pockets of space between things.
And my peripheral vision improved.
How?
My awareness of things in the visual periphery
improved.
Why?
Because when youíre cross-eyed your vision
is inefficient.
You're looking with one eye and you have to
suppress the other.
And so, as a result, you take in less of the
visual world.
Once I resolved the conflict between the two
eyes, because that's the major problem with
strabismus , not lack of stereo.
It's a visual conflict between the two eyes.
Once I resolved that conflict, by pointing
the two eyes at the same spatial location
, then I could take in more of the visual
periphery.
And so when I'm driving, I now notice that
there's a rear-view mirror off to my upper
right.
Which means that I tend to look at it more.
which makes me a much better driver.
And finally, I just want to add that many
people will say to you, "Oh, I understand
what you're saying, it's all very cool.
But if I do this, I close one eye, the world
doesn't look all that different.
So I don't really understand why you think
it's so wonderful, this stereovision business."
And, I puzzled about that for a long time,
until the day, about three years after my
vision began to change, when I went to see
the last Star Wars movie.
The Revenge of The Sith.
With my kids and my husband.
It was in 2005.
And they insisted we go on midnight of the
opening night, and I was not in the least
bit interested.
Star Wars was OK, but not worth staying up
all night for.
And being in a theater with screaming kids
and all of that.
Right?
But, my husband said this is a great family
activity.
So off we went at midnight to see the movie.
And I'm looking at the movie and I'm getting
this incredible sense of the spaceships moving
through space.
And volumes of space in the move, and all
this sort of stuff.
And I thought, ìWow, cinematography has really
improved since the last Star Wars film.î
And it was only until I had a good nightís
sleep that I realized that cinematography
wasn't all that different between Star Wars
V and Star Wars VI.
What had changed was my own visual perception.
That that sense of space and volume that I
saw in the movie was due to clever tricks
by the cinematographers using binocular depth
cues and motion cues, to evoke the sense of
depth, to evoke a sense of space and volume.
But, I couldn't appreciate that deep sense
of space and volume which was suggested by
the movie until I had actually seen it in
real life.
And so, when you just close one eye and you
look out on the world, you still have a lifetime
of stereo experiences to fill in that missing
stereo information.
But I never had that.
And when I began to first see in stereo it
was a radically different experience.
And so, I'll just end by saying that some
of you may know, well, you probably don't
know.
My husband between 1992 and 2005 was an astronaut.
He flew on the space shuttle three times.
And his space launches were absolutely spectacular
experiences.
This is a photo of his first launch in 1996,
it was a night launch.
Incredible noise and lights and sounds.
And you can feel the pressure waves of the
shuttle.
Amazing experience.
But, even that pales in comparison to first
seeing in stereo depth.
So, thank you.
[ applause ]
More questions?
>>male#8: So remind me the retina moves with
the eye right?
Like when you move the eye to look in different
directions, the retina moves along.
>>Susan Barry: Yes, it does.
The turning point is a little in front of
the retina.
>>male#8: So, the eye and the brain is actually
using the eye position to figure everything
out?
>> Susan Barry: Yeah.
And that's been a very controversial subject.
But they've now found areas in the brain that
are monitoring the position of the eye.
So they have found that and there are receptors
in the tendons of the eye, called palisade
endings, where there are sensory receptors,
for looking at how the eye is positioned in
the orbit.
And then of course your whole vestibular system
in the inner ear is devoted to how is your
head positioned on your neck.
So, yeah.
It's very important for you to know where
your eyes are.
>>male#8: Yeah, I was wondering, I mean, if
the retina was fixed and you were just [inaudible]
from an engineering standpoint.
>> Susan Barry: Yeah.
No, it's not.
Yeah?
>> male#9: So, it seems like--Iím just assuming
somebody has two eyes--there is, some place
back in here is a correlator that basically
says, ìYesî, when the two images are viewed.
>> Susan Barry: I think you're right.
>> MAM#9 : So, listening to your talk here
makes me wonder that if the young child who's
eyes wont-.
The trouble is that the correlator is broken.
The correlator isn't working right.
And I was wondering if the reason you contradicted
the doctrine.
You told me earlier you would use one eye
and then use another.
So, you were basically training both eyes.
During the plastic period you did the right
things, as opposed to what most people do.
You talked about they'd go fifteen degrees
off, put it on the blind spot, turn one eye
off and then that eye just doesnít get trained.
And that's why they never do recover.
Is this-?
>> Susan Barry: Well, yeah this makes absolute
sense.
What you're talking about, where somebody
always uses the same eye for fixation, and
always turns the other, causes the condition,
strabismic amblyopia.
Which is sometimes commonly termed, "Lazy
Eye."
But actually, there are several different
reasons why somebody can lose vision in one
eye, which seems to be brain related.
That is they didnít lose vision because there's
a problem with the eye itself.
The cornea, the lens, or something, or the
retina.
And so what youíre talking about is a condition
called strabismic amblyopia.
And youíre right, if you remain, if you alternate,
like I did, alternating strabismus.
Then the acuity in both eyes stays relatively
good for both eyes.
If you become, if you use only one eye for
fixation and turn in the other, become an
amblyopic, then the acuity in one eye goes
way down.
But it actually passed the critical period.
That also can be greatly improved.
And you can get it back.
I'm not saying it's easy, but you can.
And there also these intriguing stories.
I know one man, this happened to him.
Strabismic amblyopia like I just described,
then he lost vision in his good eye.
And, in a large percentage of cases where
that happens, vision in the amblyopic eye,
which can be awful, can sometimes recover
all the way back up to twenty- twenty.
So, it's as if the brain has suppressed that
input all these years.
But, when forced to use it, it can come back.
This doesn't happen in every case, but it
happens in enough of the cases to make one
realize that, that eye is not completely unsalvageable.
And now that scientists have embraced the
idea that vision can improve past the critical
period, and maybe they can change the name
of the critical period to something less critical.
[ laughter ]
You know, call it a sensitive period, or the
period of maximum plasticity.
Once people realize that there are studies
that are called "perceptual learning studies",
and guess what they found, gee, you take a
person who has a weak eye, an amblyopia, and
you do specific exercises with that eye it
improves.
And so you can bring back the acuity, and
probably what's even more important, is teaching
the person how to coordinate the two eyes
together.
Because, if you don't do that, even if you
bring back acuity in the amblyopic eye, but
the two eyes still aren't working together,
you are going to lose that acuity again.
Cause you're not using it.
You have to teach the person how to use the
two eyes together.
Yeah?
>> female#1: What makes somebody one-eye-dominant?
>> Susan Barry: Many of us, probably most
of us have an eye that is dominant.
And, it's actually a very confusing topic.
So, for example, you may have one eye that
is dominant for certain viewing distances,
and the other eye dominant for other viewing
distances.
So, it varies from person to person.
And from condition to condition, which eye
may be dominant.
You can all do this test, you can take your
arms and make a little window with them, like
this.
And then look at a very distant object.
Smallish object like the clock or something.
And then close one eye, and then the other.
And the image should jump when you close one
of the eyes.
And should not jump when you close the other.
You have to look in the distance.
Because what you're trying to do is make the
window so narrow, that basically only one
eye can look through it at any moment.
Yeah.
Then if you close one eye and the image jumps,
that means that was the dominant eye for that
viewing distance.
I don't know what makes an eye a dominant
eye.
>> male#10: How about when a child is young
and they're having trouble, and you're concerned
that maybe they go flat the rest of their
lives, has anybody ever tried putting a patch
over the dominant eye?
To force the-.
>> Susan Barry: Yeah, they've been doing that
for 200 years.
>>male#10: Does it work?
It sounds so easy.
[ laughter ]
>> Susan Barry: I would say there are better
approaches, but that is the standard of care.
But, is not the best approach from everything
that I've seen.
And the reason is this, that usually when
a child is suppressing one eye the problem
is not the eye itself.
The problem is with binocularity.
They donít know how to use the two eyes together.
Train them how to use the two eyes together
and they will use the two eyes together, and
the acuity in that eye will get better.
So, if you patch the good eye and you leave
the weak eye to do all the visual processing,
you'll bring up its acuity.
But, then when you stop patching, at least
the records show, that about, I forget now,
is it 30 percent?
A good percentage of kids who's acuity has
gone up in the weak eye, lose that ability.
And-.
>>male#10: So it works but itís not guaranteed,
so itís not--
>> Susan Barry: Right.
Because you're not getting at the basic problem.
The basic problem is binocular coordination
it's not the acuity of the eye alone.
So, you've got to get the eyes to work in
a binocularly coordinated way.
To solve the problem.
Yeah?
>>male#11: One vision therapist used Moro
Reflex training as part of the-.
>> Susan Barry: Yeah.
>>male#11: Can you comment on-?
>> Susan Barry: Primitive reflexes?
Yeah I can comment on it.
So, hereís-.
If you are like I was, an infantile esotrope,
it means that something went wrong in those
first months of life.
Because, you didnít develop normal binocular
vision.
So the, the question becomes, is just your
vision that was affected?
Or, are there other probes you can use to
see if there are other neurological problems
that went along with it?
Subtle ones.
Obviously not as severe as, letís say, cerebral
palsy or something.
But subtle ones.
And sometimes when you start looking, you
look at what a primitive reflex is.
The infant reflex like the Moro Reflex.
These reflexes are prominent in babies.
And then, when you grow up, they become in
the background.
You don't use them anymore.
And so, if you take a patient and you test
to see if they are still using primitive reflexes,
then it may be an indication again that during
that developmental period, when binocular
vision wasn't developing normally.
There were other neurological things not developing
normally as well.
And then, the thought might be, maybe if we
work on those reflexes as well as the vision,
try to get better bilaterality to a person,
maybe that'll help.
So, that's where I think that approach comes
from.
It's an intriguing idea.
Yeah?
>>male#12: So, I don't have stereovision but
I seem to have more peripheral vision than
other people.
>>Susan Barry: Because you exotropic.
One eye goes out?
>>male#12: Um, probably.
I think, I if I try it, I can.
>> Susan Barry: Mm-hmm.
>> male#12: But I seem to have it all the
time.
>> Susan Barry: Mm-hmm.
>>male#12: Is it something that is wrong?
Because you said you had less peripheral vision.
>>Susan Barry: Yeah.
Because, you may have-.
I had esotropia which meant that when I looked
with one eye the other eye turned in.
If you have exotropia that means when you
look with one eye and the other eye turns
out.
And you may be taking in-.
If you think about it, it gives you a wider
visual field.
Right?
If you combine both eyes, you've got a wider
visual field.
And so, then you are able-.
Then you have a wider visual field.
So the fact is then you might see more peripherally
than a person who has straight eyes.
And, in fact, when surgery is done on person
with exotropia, the eye turning out, they
are upset, because after the surgery they
no longer have this wider peripheral field.
Because, that other eye has been more turned
in as well.
There's a- I canít remember his name- but
he's the leading base stealer ever in baseball.
And he had this condition.
An intermittent exotropia.
Where he could turn in his eyes and see in
3D, and use that to hit the baseball.
But, when he was on the bases, he could both
look at the picture and look elsewhere at
the same time.
He could diverge his eyes in that way with
his exotropia.
[ laughter ]
And thereby have a better view of the world
and steal those bases.
So, there may be advantages to that way of
seeing.
[ laughter ]
>>male#12: No, I'm sometimes joking that if
I could get stereovision, I'm not sure I would
want it.
Because I have several aspects that the eyes
work better than--
>>Susan Barry: And that's--.
Yeah.
>>male #12: than they would most people.
>>Susan Barry: Right.
And yeah.
So then, it really does become a question
of--.
It's a trade-off.
And to get the stereovision, even if you,
let's say, you'd have to work at it.
But if you can do both and some can, they
can pull in their eyes and then let them go
out, then it could work.
But usually, if you're in that situation,
it takes more effort to pull in your eyes
than normal.
And so, it's more effort to see in 3D.
>>male #12: Right.
>>Susan Barry: And so, you're less likely
to want to do it.
Yeah.
>>male #13: I understand there's these things
called saccades.
>>Susan Barry: Yeah.
Rapid eye movement.
>>male #13: I'm looking at that.
I think I'm looking at the space shuttle there,
but what's really happening is my eyes are
going, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop, pop.
>> Susan Barry: Right.
>>male#13: 15 hundred milliseconds or so,
and they're probably, basically, filling up
a poster board of evidence.
Well anyway, my first question is, do those
saccades happen same time in both eyes?
So they're eyes are popping together.
And second, I was just wondering if in the
case of somebody with strabismus when theyíre
young, that maybe that's not working.
And is there any evidence?
It would seem to me a very easy thing to measure.
>> Susan Barry: Right.
Right.
>male#13: Is it the case?
>>Susan Barry: Well, if you look at saccades,
saccades can be of two types.
Conjugate or disconjugate.
Conjugate would mean both eyes going in the
same direction at the same time.
So youíre watching a tennis match in both
eyes.
Swivel to the right when the ball goes to
the right, and both eyes swivel to the left
when the ball goes to the left.
Right and left and right and left.
That's a conjugate saccade.
And I don't think there's any evidence to
indicate that that's not normal in somebody
with strabismus.
When you make a vergence movement, turning
in both eyes to see something close, or turning
them out to see something further away.
That actually takes much more time than a
rapid saccade.
And by the way saccade are the very fastest
movements we can make, period.
You know, conjugate saccade.
So when youíre turning in your eyes or turning
them out, it takes more time.
Those are also a kind of saccade and those
are not normal in somebody with strabismus.
In fact, they may not be existent.
Yeah.
And those are not normal.
That's basically what I learned to train.
My fusion ranges are wonderful, in terms of
what I can fuse.
But, it does take me longer than average to
go from looking close to looking far.
to make the vergance movements back and forth.
So, still working on that.
One last question.
>>female #2: So, I have pretty normal vision
except that I am near sighted.
But, it's harder for me, and I think for most
people, to have good depth perception at dusk.
>> Susan Barry: Mm-hmm.
>>female#2: And possibly also at dawn , but
I'm also not as often awake at dawn.
[ laughter ]
>>female#2: So, I donít have as much data
on that one.
But I was wondering why that is.
>>Susan Barry: I think because you add up
all the cues you use.
And so, at dusk light is dimmer.
They are all monocular cues to depth.
Perspective, object occlusion.
I know for example that, if my hand is blocking
my view of the video camera, I know my hand's
in front of the video camera.
Object occlusion.
Perspective, motion parallax, shading and
shadows, give you a sense of roundness and
depth.
Those all come from one eye.
And you combine those with your sense of stereo
depth to see.
And so as those cues begin to fade because
the light is beginning to fade.
Your depth perception is going to go down.
>>female#2: It seems odd though that it's
actually better at night.
>>Susan Barry: Your depth perception- you're
saying it's better at night.
>>female#2: If I am playing tennis with my
dad for example, and it's getting to be evening,
and so there's still light, you can still
see.
I can still see the net.
I can still see the line on the court, and
I suck. [ laughs ] and then it gets dark and
there's a light on the court, and-
>>Susan Barry: Oh.
I see what you're saying.
You're getting better.
Yeah.
My guess would be because the light is coming
in obliquely, and casting shadows as a result
of its obliqueness.
And you're taking real advantage of that and
combining that with your stereovision to see
better.
That would be my guess as to what's going
on.
Because, I've noticed that too, not so much
playing tennis, but, if I am looking at a
tree that's in the dark, but thereís a street
light casting light on the tree at an angle,
I'll get this incredible sense of depth now
from it.
Which I think is a combination of the oblique
light coming in setting up certain shades
and shadows, combines with my stereo.
And it gives me this wonderful sense of depth,
and maybe, that's what you're getting.
So take a look and see what the lighting situation
is like.
>>male#14: I have the tennis thing too.
Since I don't have stereovision, I only estimate
where the ball is by the angle in which it
moves.
So, the light that's coming in and how many
light sources there are plays a big role.
>> Susan Barry: Right.
Right.
Because you're using that oblique light.
Yeah.
Right.
And I found when I was stereo blind, the worst
thing was having to climb down outside steps
at noon.
You know why?
Because the light is directly overhead , there
are no shadows.
And so, everything flattens out.
Especially if you don't have stereovision.
So, people have asked me for advice about
when you're stereo blind, I said don't try
to walk down steps at high noon.
[ laughter ]
Yeah.
Thank you.
[ applause ]